Olá a todos estou de volta depois de 5
anos de não fazer nada ah é um pouco
estranho estar aqui a falar em português
para uma câmara vou só explicar o que é
que aconteceu nos últimos 5 anos quais
são os planos para o futuro Isto é para
as pessoas que têm escrito mensagens e
perguntado o que aconteceu pronto Olá a
todos de novo ah porque é que eu parei
de fazer vídeos que eu já não estava a
conseguir fazer dinheiro com o YouTube
suficiente para eu poder fazer isto a
tempo inteiro chegou um momento em que
as visua sões estavam a baixar a
tendência era sempre para baixar e o
dinheiro estava a baixar ainda mais
rápido que as visualizações então eu
pensei Ok eu preciso fazer alguma coisa
para combater isso então eu pensei posso
tentar fazer dinheiro de outra forma e
assim continuar a produzir vídeos então
fiz este livro aqui gostei muito do
processo investi bastante tempo Estou
bastante eh feliz com o resultado porém
eu não consegui vender muitas cópias
vendi metade das 1000 cópias que eu fiz
e então eu estava bastante desanimado e
não conseguia ver uma maneira de fazer
com que fosse sustentável Eu produzir
vídeos então eu pensei Ok enquanto o
barco ainda está a fundar que eu ainda
fazia algum dinheiro com o YouTube na
altura vou mudar de rumo Então decidi
vir para Inglaterra ter com os meus pais
aí durante mais ou menos aí uns nove
meses uma coisa assim Fiz trabalho do
hotel estive na construção e também
estive a trabalhar num num Armazém para
tratar lá da organização das Caixas
dessas coisas todas depois desse período
eu pensei Ok o que é que eu vou fazer
com a minha vida pensei eu devo
continuar com os meus estudos porque
antes disse e eu fiz dois anos de
colégio a estudar sobre jogos e
multimídia também fiz um pequeno curso
na world Academy em Lisboa que também
foi muito bom aprendi bastantes coisas
lá então pronto fui para a universidade
estudei efeitos visuais durante 3 anos
aprendi imensas coisas Estou bastante
satisfeito com o curso mas infelizmente
quando acabei o mercado de trabalho
estava péssimo hum
houve greve dos escritores lá na América
e depois houve a greve dos actores e
Isso acabou por afetar bastante o
mercado porque se não se produzir filmes
nós não vamos ter coisas filmadas para
adicionar os efeitos visuais por cima
para me adaptar a esta situação comecei
a produzir vídeos destes Que Vocês
conseguem ver agora e foi muito bom que
eu fiz isto e algumas pessoas começaram
a contactar-me para eu fazer vídeos
destes para eles também e de momento
tenho andado a sustentar fazendo este
tipo de de efeitos especiais que são
bastante rápidos de fazer consigo fazer
muito melhor mas isso demora bxo tempo e
como o Budget eles é pequeno então eu
faço algo com pouco dinheiro essa é a
ideia pois eh fiz também outra coisa que
estou bastante animado eu em 2019
comecei a produzir um jogo que se chama
Bunker Strike que é um jogo de tabuleiro
em que envolve estratégia habilidade eh
e um pouco de sorte que tem-se que
lançar o dado e é o jogo que vocês estão
a ver aqui agora e eu lancei este jogo
na plataforma de kickstarter basicamente
é uma plataforma de crowdfunding se
vocês quiserem saber mais sobre isso eu
vou deixar na descrição mas a ideia eh
principal é o seguinte tu tens um
produto e dizes Olha eu tenho este
produto gostava de produzir e vender
para vocês se houver eh suficiente
pessoas interessadas no assunto e se o
valor dessas pessoas todas interessadas
for mais do valor do que tu pedes aí sim
eu vou produzir o jogo para todos vocês
no meu caso eu preciso de 10.000 pounds
para poder produzir o jogo para as
pessoas que estiverem interessadas se eu
não chegar a essa meta o dinheiro nunca
vai sair das contas bancárias das
pessoas que disseram lá que tem
interesse em comprar e o jogo Ah mas
vejo uma descrição para vocês entenderem
melhor porque acho que não fiz um
trabalho muito bom a explicar Hum E
agora eu lancei esta campanha e estou a
tentar chegar aos 10.000 pounds para
poder comprar a máquina de corta laser e
produzir este jogo e a ideia para o
futuro é tentar fazer jogos destes e
metê-lo no mercado pronto esta é a minha
primeira tentativa eu espero bem que
seja de sucesso Ah estou um bocado roso
porque Ah o meu Budget para publicidade
é quase zero e é isso se vocês puderem
comprar um jogo pá eu ficava bastante
agradecido mas sei que isso a
probabilidade se acontecer é muito
pequena porque a maior parte do público
é do Brasil e h e e eu por exemplo não
vou mandar o jogo para o Brasil porque é
absurdamente caro mandar o jogo para lá
mas se pronto se forem de Portugal e
quiserem comprar o jogo eu ficaria
bastante grato se ajudaria a começar a
minha carreira Nesta parte de criação de
jogos em relação ao futuro do canal eu
eu não sei eu gostaria muito de voltar e
fazer vídeos mas H É muito difícil
investir tempo numa coisa que não não
seja viável se eu encontrar alguém que
queira ok nós vamos Patrocinar o teu
conteúdo todos os meses tens x dinheiro
e é só usares as nossas ferramentas por
exemplo pá Eu adoraria trabalhar nesse
formato teria todo o prazer em fazê-lo
Mas se eu não encontrar ninguém quer
fazer isso ah não vai dar para voltar e
eu vou ter que focar mais na parte de
efeitos visuais Ah e de criação de jogos
muito bom ouvir que muitos de vocês já
estão a estudar engenharia muitos já
terminaram engenharia Ah isso enche o
meu coração de felicidade Hum E é isso
ah tudo bom para vocês Ah é estranho é
estranho esta parte não sei não sei bem
passam muitas coisas pela minha cabeça
agora ah foram foram muitos anos a
trabalhar a fazer vídeos e e chega o
momento em que Ok não não Consegues lev
isto para a frente Ah eu sei que pronto
que isto não vai para a frente também
porque que eu falhei nesta coisa de
conseguir encontrar uma forma de fazer H
as coisas funcionarem não é Ah mas
pronto a realidade e aceitar e ir em
frente é isso obrigado por tudo e
adeus